et si la relance de l'activité
économique passée par l'innovation
technologique dans l'économie verte
c'est une part de la stratégie choisie
par le groupe emi tech spécialisée dans
les tests de qualification et
d'homologation
elle a relancé son activité notamment
sur des batteries destinées à des
véhicules électriques
là dessus sur tout ce qui est véhiculé
hybrides ou tout électriques bon on a un
très très bon marché très fort et on
développe actuellement je pense des
nouvelles méthodes d'essai pour que
demain on puisse mieux tester tous les
véhicules journal décidé de lancer des
bandes test de moteurs électriques et
cela testé et dans des cages de faraday
pour mesurer les perturbations
éventuellement émises par ces moteurs et
aussi d'un des chambre anéchoïque
acoustique voir ou écouter plutôt si les
moteurs ne pompent la peau bruit avec
ces méthodes de tests innovantes emitech
devrait recevoir une troisième batterie
en septembre à partir du mois d'octobre
des tests seront lancés sur des piles à
combustible à hydrogène
le véhicule vers un moyen pour ce groupe
de 500 salariés de relancer son activité
sous traitant de grands groupes la crise
sanitaire a eu des conséquences
importantes sur cette société bat
donneurs d'ordre donc pas de chiffre
d'affaires ou très très peu sur des
affaires qu'on avait commencé donc en
avril mais on tournait à 40 % de chiffre
d'affaires dans l'automobile que dans
l'aéronautique a rien eu du tout moi
soyons clairs donc pendant quatre
pendant dix semaines et aujourd'hui leur
nautique c'est le calme plat mais
l'automobile commence à frémir grâce aux
chiffres et aux véhicules verts pour
cette entreprise implantée à montigny le
bretonneux les deux tiers de l'activité
sont réalisés dans l'aéronautique et
l'automobile
ils représentent plus de 60% des
missions de l'entreprise en 2019